[Musique]
françois bayrou est l'invité de bfm
politique pour cette dernière de la
saison commissaire au plan maire de pau
président du modem évidemment nous
allons nous intéresser la situation
sanitaire l'intervention du président de
la république demain à 20h très attendu
vous nous décrire est également le
contenu de votre dernière note consacrée
à l'agriculture chez que c'est un sujet
qui vous tient à coeur mais avant ça je
voulais commencer en vous montrant des
images qui ont marqué l'opinion ces
dernières heures s'est passé hier soir
au festival de cannes
le comédien pio marmaï incarna un
chauffeur routier dans le film la
fracture qui était projeté voici ce
qu'il dit en conférence de presse en
marge de la projection de ce film je
précise que la phrase que vous allez
entendre passer par les tuyaux et vous
allez comprendre
il à reprendre son personnage dans le
film mais voici ce qu'il dit pour une
fois macron jeu j'aurais bien allé chez
lui en passant par les chiffres étaient
par les tuyaux et lui péter la gueule
c'est évidemment mais avec un peu comme
tout le monde dans l'absolu mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est se dire enfin
comment est ce qu'on raconte cette
révolte quoi qu'est-ce qu'elle passe par
la langue ou par ou par l'acte de
violence vers quelque chose mais moi
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de raconter
parce que je pars j'étais sensible à ça
parce que c'est pas évident comme comme
le trajectoire voilà ce que dit pio
marmaï françois bayrou macron j'irais
bien par les chocs par les deux studios
et reprend les mots de son personnage
pour les casser la gueule un peu comme
tout ouais je me doutais bien que vous
me poseriez la question valeur j'ai
regarder d'un peu près là la séquence
d'abord on se dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est des propos de bistrot par
quelqu'un qui a qu'un coup dans l'oeil
comme on dit en réalité c'est pas
exactement ça donc il est interrogé
je crois par une journaliste qui dit
qu'est ce que vous diriez au président
de la république aux manuels mal qu'on
s'il était en face de vous et donc il
il cite cette réplique qui est celle de
son personnage
ce que j'ai juste avant leur gilet jaune
et vous c'est vrai un camionneur gilet
jaune dans dans le film
après déroule quatre ou cinq phrases est
finie c'est plus intéressant on lui dit
messi
il dit si macron était là je lui dirais
mon pote qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans ce
monde ou quelque chose comme ça
qu'est-ce qui va pas là je trouve que la
fin de la séquence est plus intéressante
que le début mais vous avez entre les
mains un instrument formidable qui
déclenche des patients la télé les
réseaux sociaux ça déclenche des
passions
même quand c'est pas forcément je pense
ne pensais pas forcément justifiée je
pense que c'est une phrase qui isolé est
une phrase insupportable dans le
déroulement de sa réponse s'est il fait
parler un gilet jaune et il dit si
macron été là je lui dirais qu est-ce
qui va pas mon pote dans ce monde et la
question qu'est-ce qui va pas dans ce
monde est une question pour tout le
monde
alors là on a quasiment 50 minutes pour
tenter de répondre partiellement à cette
question françois bayrou évidemment
c'est un rendez vous très attendu par
les français de demain à 20 heures
emmanuel macron prendra la parole
allocutions qui était prévu depuis un
moment mais qui pourrait prendre une
tournure différente en raison de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire ou
si vous êtes proche du chef de l'état
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur le contenu de cette intervention
demain le vous savez je joue je suis
frappée d'amnésie dès qu'il s'agit des
qu'on m'interroge sur ce que pense le
président de la république parce que
c'est sa responsabilité qui va
s'exprimer demain soir ma position à moi
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'autre issue dans
cette situation épidémique que la
vaccination obligatoire pour tout le
monde et on présente ça comme si c'était
quelque chose de deux attentatoires aux
libertés chacun des bébé qui naît en
france reçoit 11 vaccination 11
d'ailleurs l'injection des onze avait
fait débat en juin l'avait emporté et
puis vous voyez bien qu'il n'ya aucun
effet négatif ou secondaire vous avez
tetra coop comme on disait autrefois
diphtérie de pauline haas polio
coqueluche rougeole rubéole qui font des
morts et des bébés et d aider et des
handicaps pour l'un pour la ville à pau
lyon là éradiquer comme ça et le nombre
de deux jeunes qui étaient atteints par
la polio et qui pouvaient plus déplacés
ou était embarrassé pour se déplacer on
l'a éradiquer comme ça la vaccination
c'est un traitement naturel de
renforcement de l'immunité de chaque
alors françois bayrou au fond l'académie
l'académie de médecine a dit ce que vous
aviez dit la semaine dernière en
préconisant la vaccination obligatoire
pour tout le monde à partir de l'âge de
12 ans mais je souhaite vous porter la
contradiction parce que le sujet vous
dites les onze vaccin pour nos enfants
voilà sont obligatoires et ce sont des
vaccins anciens et le conseil d'état va
être saisie dès mardi
parce que les vaccins contre lacko vide
19 sont des vaccins récent qui
d'ailleurs sont toujours en phase 4 de
test et n'ont en réalité qu'une au
modèle homologation d'urgence qui leur a
été accordée par les autorités
européennes françaises donc il ya ce
sujet là et ce sujet va être porté
devant le conseil d'état est ce que vous
ancien garde des sceaux vous le balayer
d'un revers de la main
je balaie rien je vois notre pays et
l'humanité menacée par un virus qui a
bloqué la vie de l'ensemble des pays de
l'ensemble de l'europe et d'une grande
partie de la planète qui portent
atteinte aux libertés à la rencontre au
fait qu'on puisse je vois ce virus sa
gravité je sais une chose de ce virus
c'est qu'il mute il a constamment de
nouveaux épisodes de mutation et jeu
dit une chose j'espère de toutes mes
forces me tromper mais ma hantise à moi
c'est que une de ces mutations se
mettent à toucher les enfants et les
bébés
le jour où vous aurez des enfants qui
mouraient qui mouraient du du virus ce
jour là vous ne de la société explosera
parce que seront mis en accusation tous
ceux qui n'ont pas pris les décisions
nécessaires alors qu' il ya une chose
qui crève les yeux il ya combien 35 36
millions de français qui ont été
vaccinées où sont les effets secondaires
donc vous dites à emmanuel macron pas de
demi-mesure lundi soir vaccination
obligatoire tout ce jeu je parle en mon
propre nom je pense que la seule issue
possible
c'est la vaccination obligatoire pour
qu'on retrouve autant que possible la
vue la vie et qu'on se sécurise qu'on se
met en sécurité
en face des mutations du virus il ya une
loi c'est plus le plus le virus circule
plus il mute françois bayrou yaka et
d'orient si on veut se prémunir contre
les mutations les plus dramatiques qui
peuvent arriver
alors il faut ralentir la circulation du
virus est pour ralentir la circulation
du virus
il n'y a qu'une chose à faire ou bien
laisser infecté tout le monde et vous
aurez des à nouveau des dizaines de
milliers de morts parce qu'on a quand
même
comme vous savez et des mutations un
nombre de mains et vous aurez des
mutations est le seul moyen de freiner
tout cela c'est c'est la vaccination en
plus la vaccination c'est formidable
progrès français par un d un des
français les plus géniaux de tous les
temps qui s'appelle louis pasteur et
mcfc en 8 - géniaux sur la course aux
accents aoûtiens on a été moins bon
depuis
c'est une hausse arrivera ça arrivera
c'est une question très importante mais
peut-être on pourrait en parler dans la
suite comme vous le savez dans le cadre
de mes de mes fonctions du plan et des
notes j'ai édité une note sur ce sujet
françois méro il ya quand même une
question si la vaccination est rendue
obligatoire notamment pour les ceux qui
travaillent dans les ehpad
puisqu'on en parle qu'est ce qu'on fait
si quelqu'un refuse de se faire vacciner
est ce qu on le licencie
idem pour les entreprises je passe le
début de l'appel à la vaccination de
geoffroy roux de bézieux le président du
medef comme laurent berger la cfdt en
entreprise vous refusez de vous faire
vacciner qu'est ce qui se passe vous
êtes licencié vous êtes en télétravail
de fils mais c'est comment vous gérez ça
je précise que ça peut aller jusque là
c'est le cas en italien oui absolument
j'avais mal et je regarde ont des choses
en face il ya onze pays d'afrique plus
départements français la guyane où on ne
peut pas aller sans être vaccinés contre
la fièvre jaune obligatoire si vous êtes
représentant de commerce et que vous
dites je veux pas être vaccinés pour ne
pas vous ne pouvez plus à lille n'a pas
tant dans ces pays
et ben oui vous avez des envies
professionnelles encore une fois c'est
fait de nouveau c'est de la non
assistance à personne en danger
mais soyons précis vous avez vu cette
jeune femme dont un dont le père est
mort il ya la saisie premier ministre
pour réparation il avait une affection
il a attrapé le vide à l'hôpital il est
mort et elle dit si vous aviez été
vaccinées alors mon père ne serait pas
mais soyons précis vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants on sait
que le texte est en préparation sera
présentée au conseil d'état conseil des
ministres ça semble lancée même lancé ma
position mais plus large que celle là
oui parce que cibler seulement les
soignants oui ils ont le sentiment de
quelque chose qui n'est pas juste parce
que vous avez les enseignants c'est la
rentrée scolaire dans quelques semaines
vous avez beaucoup de professions qui
sont au contact du public et donc le
ma position à moi et plus largement on
verra ce que dit le président de
république mais on sait que la piste une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants est très sérieuse puisque un
texte étant est en préparation
qu'est-ce qu'on fait françois bayrou
avec dans l'hôpital public dans
l'hôpital public
je précise bien si un aide soignant une
infirmière refusent de se faire vacciner
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quelque chose que
vous feriez dans l'hôpital public
si un chirurgien refusait de se
désinfecter les mains et de mettre des
gants pour une opération diriez écoutez
monsieur l sera sanctionné on dirait
seulement vous pouvez pas exercer votre
pour vous c'est la même chose
vous voyez bien ce qu'on est en train de
vivre
combien de morts on a eu dans les ehpad
non mais dites nous alors donc la
personne en question ne peut plus les
unités sont dispendieux son travail ce
qui peut apporter un cadre plus large à
l'aspect coercitif j'ai à dire à
l'envers c'est le pass sanitaire ça fera
peut-être partie des annonces des
manières macron demain en fait c'est
l'incitation forte c'est la carotte dire
aux français ben si vous voulez aller au
restaurant vous faites vacciner voulez
voyager vous faites vacciner sinon je
n'en avais pas le droit c'est un peu le
prolongement de ce que vous demande de
dire à l'instant est ce que c'est une
piste qui vous semblent pertinentes
c'est une piste pertinente que vous avez
c'est bien j'entends bien et je respecte
parce que il n'y a pas de raison de
faire des polémiques inutiles sur ce
sujet la position de ceux qui doutent
mais vous avez 35 millions de français
aujourd'hui peut-être plus j'ai pas
regardé l'actualisation des chiffres qui
disent nous on s'est fait vacciner et on
va pas avoir accès aux voyages aux
rencontres on risque de se retrouver à
nouveau bloqués dans notre métier
s'il y a à nouveau
ce renfermement tout ça parce qu'il ya
des gens qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner
l'effort que nous avons fait nous les
autres ne veulent pas mais la fracture
nationale il est bien il faut lever le
moyen de lever cette fracture comme on
dit c'est évidemment le pass and iter
est allé vers la vaccination alors
obligatoire ce qui est ma position
précis sur l'extension du pass
sanitaires à vos yeux avoue françois
bayrou il faut le pass sanitaires pour
aller au restaurant pour aller au cinéma
pour aller à la salle de sport soyons
précis
c'est là il des gens il ne se passera
pas trois semaines avant qu'on ait cette
obligation parce que les restaurateurs
vous rendez compte ils sont ils ont
cessé de travailler pendant presque 18
mois
alors ils ont été aidés puissamment on
est le pays du monde qui a le plus aidé
ces entreprises et ils le savent bien
enfin on va pas les condamner à refuser
ou à abandonner leur métier simplement
parce que il ya des craintes infondées
qui existe je retiens ne se passera pas
trois semaines donc l'obligation pour le
restaurant le cinéma mais ça vous dirait
les yeux monde mon métier j'allais dire
ma vocation c'est de regarder le réel
c'est pas de faire des fantasmes ou de
participer aux luttes de fantasmes c'est
le ce qui m'intéresse c'est le réel
comme il se vit et le réel c'est on est
obligé de réouvrir la vie de réouvrir
les activités de réouvrir les stades de
réouvrir les restaurants de réouvrir
l'enregistrer en partie les frontières
et puisque vous partez de parler du réel
l'espagne on y va ou pas prévu que les
membres qui est dit bah non je vous
déconseille real qui a provoqué un mini
incident diplomatique puisque nos amis
espagnols et portugais n'était pas du
tout content de ça mais quand vous avez
des pays où le virus circule activement
alors sauf à être vaccinés eh bien il
est prudent de ne pas y aller c'est
toujours une amara sauf que cela la
sévère par la france il
ad il ya des régions en espagne est mal
comme nous risquons de l'être bientôt
avec une résurgence du virus
il ya des pays quand même qu'il commence
au sein de l'union européenne comme
malte qui a donc décidé de fermer ses
frontières ce qui ne sont pas vaccinés
j'en veux dire c'est un petit peu déjà
la fin d'une du passeport sanitaires non
européens puisque mal fait partie de
l'union européenne mais on veut on vient
de mener non on va on va droit tout ça
le musée la tête d'un pays
vous avez la responsabilité d'une
société vous avez des millions de vies
sur les bras don don dont l'obligation
morale et que vous vous occupiez et bien
de ce point de vue là vous prenez les
précautions nécessaires
alors il ya des réticences ou des
résistances bas vous croyez que les 35
ou 38 millions de personnes vaccinées
il ya trois mois elle avait des
réticences et aujourd'hui ben elles se
rendent compte que tout ce qu'elles
avaient craint est infondée bon il ya à
la deuxième injection parfois parfois la
première 48 heures inconfortable où on a
un peu de un peu de fièvre c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé à beaucoup d'entre nous
mais c'est pas une raison pour choisir
de bloquer la vie alors lequel à vis
d'un pays
loc arrêtons nous un quart de seconde
comment va-t-on faire pour assumer la
solidarité
si on ne travaille pas si on peut pas
sortir s'il n'y a pas de vie si on peut
pas voyager sahara si le monde à
l'action oui bien sûr je pense que
beaucoup d'entre eux y pense un françois
bayrou débloquer la vie mais peut être
aussi en faisant attention je crois que
vous êtes plutôt rugby que football mais
ce soit vous regarderez sans doute la
finale de la coupe d'europe angleterre
italie à wembley stade londonien 65
mille spectateurs sont attendus
on sait que le delta est monté en flèche
au royaume uni est ce que ces
responsables c'est
c'est pas très prudent c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire je suis comme comme
vous l'avez rappelé très très attaché au
sport j'aime ça mais je pense que la
vaccination est une précaution
nécessaire parce que quand on crie quand
on hurle dans les tribunes quand on
saute comme on le voit sur sur votre
écran
évidemment la circulation du virus
s'accélère donc la mutation du virus est
favorisée donc l'uefa n'a pas été
prudente
oui je pense que je pense que je ne sais
pas ce ne sont pas des images très
rassurante
vous avez parlé d aide puissante
financière de l'état pour les
professionnels qui ont beaucoup souffert
en france il ya un système un dispositif
qui était très utilisé très efficace et
le pg le prêt garanti par l'état sauf
que les chances arrivent les chances
arrive vous ces entreprises vont devoir
commencer à rembourser ce prêt très
avantageux alors elle les cinq ans oui
mais ça s'approche il faudra refaire de
la trésorerie certains ne l'ont pas
certains ont déjà épuisé le pge qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont contractés est-ce que
vous joignez votre voix celles qui
demandent l'annulation simple de ce pg e
s qui demande qu'on n'efface attardo à
ce que ce soit un cadeau fait par l'état
je suis très mal à l'aise
chaque fois qu'on commence par un prêt
et qu'on demande l'effacement du prêt je
suis très mal à l'aise parce que alors
je ne doute pas que d'ici cinq ans on
aura une réflexion de cet ordre fut très
mal à l'aise parce que ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le doute s'installe dès
l'instant que vous signez un prêt et si
le doute s'installe alors le prix de
l'argent explose le les taux d'intérêt
montent eux qu'est ce que c'est les taux
d'intérêt c'est la traduction dans la
mensualité qu'on vous demande du risque
pris par celui qui vous plaît et ce qui
ce passe de cinq entreprises on est
d'accord ça se passe au niveau de la
france notamment puisque je sais pas si
vous avez entendu eric woerth le
président de la commission des finances
ancien ministre que vous connaissez bien
il l'a dit l'heure des comptes a sonné
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
ce que justement ce quoi qu'il en coûte
il faut quand même y mettre un terme
même s'il se passe une quatrième vague
parce que sinon la rippe
tu as sur la france elle va être
exactement ce que vous venez de
démontrer
elle va être là elle va être dégradée
donc et taux d'intérêt vont augmenter
donc la dette vente etc etc
est ce que vous êtes d'accord l'heure
des comptes a sonné d'abord l'heure des
comptes sonne tous les jours enfin on
peut se poser la question en ce moment
comme vous savez il ya vingt ans que je
plaide pour que en fait scrupuleusement
il prudemment les comptes sur sur ces
affaires là j'ai publié avec le plan une
note sur ce sujet précis une orientation
sur ce sujet précis et j'ai dit deux
choses la première la dette que nous
avons contracté pour faire face aux
conséquences de cette épidémie qu'à vide
n'est pas une dette comme les autres ça
n'est pas une dette de mauvaise gestion
c'est ce que j'ai appelé une dette de
guerre
quand vous êtes à la tête d'un pays et
que vous êtes attaqués par des armées il
voulait arrêter dans les voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est que maintenant les
sombres je prends votre raisonnement là
gloucester dont maintenant vous vous
avez compris parce que vous êtes prouver
intelligente
merci et est très spécialiste en
économie de dévoués vous suivez ça mais
ceux qui nous écoutent mérite qu'on
entend c'est une dette de guerre une
dette qu'on a été obligés de contracter
cette date là on peut reporter
l'échéance dans les années qui viennent
j'ai dit disant à peu près pour que on
arrive au temps où on aura reconstruit
l'économie et on pourra commencer à
rembourser
pourquoi parce que on emprunte à zéro en
ce moment que vous savez parfois même
des tonnes mais il ya une deuxième
décision orientation à mes yeux qu'il
faut prendre que j'ai appelé un plan
marshall de reconquête de la production
on va en parler pour l'agriculture mais
pour l'industrie c'est la même chose il
y à des secteurs entiers de la
production que dont nous avons été
chassés exclu danse par négligence par
nullité par incapacité de tous ceux qui
se sont succédé au pouvoir et qui au
fond considérer que
le les productions soit en france ou en
extrême orient c'était la même chose
pour des commerçants c'est la même chose
mais pour des producteurs pour des
industriels pour l'emploi c'est pas la
même pour les compétences du pays c'est
pas la même chose et donc je dis il faut
ce que j'ai appelé un plan marshall pas
forcément financé par la dette
il ya peut-être ya je crois d'autres
possibilités que la dette pour mobiliser
par exemple l' épargne de manière
garanti et sécurisé pour les français
mais aux sorties obligatoires
donc on a besoin les américains l'ont
fait de pouvoir faire un report des
remboursements jusqu'au moment où on a
reconstruit tout ça et c'est tout à fait
articulable en raison du fait que nous
sommes dépendants d'une grande banque
centrale que nous avons des taux à zéro
heureusement que maastricht au sujet de
notre endettement et de nos capacités à
financer notre modèle social
manuel macron parle demain nous
attendrons tous de savoir ce qu'il va
dire au sujet de la réforme des
retraites
c'était une promesse une priorité de son
quinquennat
bousculé par la pandémie est ce qu'il
doit la maintenir alors c'est une
obligation la france n'y échappera pas
ceux qui vous racontent qu'on peut
éviter la réforme des retraites ne voit
pas le monde comme il est en tout cas
que comme
de manière réaliste nous le voyons tous
vous voyez bien tout ce qui s'est passé
avec l'allongement de la durée de la vie
avec le raccourcissement des années au
travail on va être dans l'obligation de
conduire une réforme
j'espère j'espère simple j'espère bien
équilibrée sur ce sujet mais je ne crois
pas que avant l'élection présidentielle
dans le le la fournaise d'une campagne
présidentielle je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse conduire sereinement une réforme
à son terme ce que je crois c'est que
les de la campagne d'élection
présidentielle va être le lieu le moment
pour que chacun dise ses orientations
sur ce sujet et vous pensez qu'il va
vous écouter sur ce coup le président de
la république je pense je vois là la
malice de votre question je pense qu'ils
m'écoutent plus souvent que vous ne
croyez nous verrons la souvent que je le
dis à mme m mais après tout ce n'est pas
un concours
le responsable du pays et lui c'est lui
il a autour de lui avec lui des des
personnalités qui peuvent l'aider à
conduire une réflexion mais la décision
au bout du compte c'est lui qui l'a
prévenu lé président est ce qu'elle est
prise à l'heure où nous parlons
amnésie vous savez ce truc récurrentes
je sais pas pourquoi je l'achète on va
préciser les choses lors du manceau
d'aero évidemment donc vous dit pas
avant l'élection présidentielle mais
toute première chose du quinquennat
prochain si jamais mené le maquereau est
réélu ou quelle que soit la personne qui
sera élu selon vous elle devra faire
cette demande dès le début de ma vie est
chère mais rien n'avance rien n'avoir
pas une mesure d'âge rien avant j'ai
j'ai défendu très souvent l'idée que le
problème avec une réforme aussi profonde
que celle là c'est que le seul fait de
l'énoncé bloquent le pays et on a vécu
ça tragiquement pendant des mois et des
mois et des mois
est ce que je crois moi que alors ça
c'est à titre absolument personnelle
c'est que le seul moyen d'éviter qu'une
telle réforme ne bloquent le pays
c'est de dire aux français c'est vous
qui trancherait pas référendum on va
faire la réforme la plus juste possible
la mieux équilibrée possible on vous la
soumettra et c'est vous qui trouvez la
complexité d'une réforme des retraites
par référendum oui non mais vous voyez
bien seul moyen d'éviter le blocage
masisi vous fait élire président de la
république sur a été présenté c'est vrai
que c'est une sorte de référendum par
avance mais mais mais mais moi je crois
que le que le cet équilibre là qui fait
que les français seraient à la fois
informer et sécurisé et puis si garderai
le dernier mot c'est un progrès
démocratique auquel je crois on devra
aller je pense sur le fond qu on ne se
sert pas assez de larmes du référendum
parce qu'on en fait une espèce de 2,2 de
jugement de l'action du président de la
république et s'y perd et s'en va pas du
tout comme ça qu'il faut faire il faut
faire des référendums davantage proche
de ce que fait la suisse
c'est à dire c'est vous français qui
trancherait et après tout vous avez bien
le droit de trancher dans un sens ou
dans l'autre et j'ai proposé ça pour les
modes de scrutin est pour un sens à un
mot rapide quand même et c'est important
sur les jeunes on sait que les jeunes
ont été très touchés par cette crise
sanitaire et que le président a un
public réfléchit à une mesure en faveur
des jeunes il est hostile
un rsa jeunes mais en revanche d'une
garantie universelle qui serait étendu
pour faciliter l'insertion des jeunes
dans le travail mais ce que vous êtes
favorable est ce que vous pensez que il
faut absolument une mesure mais une
mesure ciblée sur la notion de il faut
s'insérer dans la société
je pense que il n'ya pas de meilleur
service à rendre des jeunes
jeune fille des jeunes hommes que de
leur offrir l'entrée dans le monde du
travail est de les soutenir quand il
entre dans le monde du travail et donc
de ce point de vue là oui je suis
favorable à une mesure de soutien et
d'ouverture des portes pour le travail
vous l'avez vu évidemment les cyber
harceleur de la jeune mila ont été
condamnés à des peines assez légères
certains ont été relaxés d'ailleurs la
jeune femme qui s'est par ailleurs
déplacé la grande mosquée de paris dans
un un signe d'apaisement
est ce que cette affaire françois hébert
ol n'illustre pas la très grande
difficulté à faire vivre la laïcité à la
française
et je précise d'ailleurs pour ses
téléspectateurs qui n'auraient pas vu
que ce qui s'appelait l'observatoire la
laïcité a été éteint remplacé la semaine
qui vient par le comité sur la laïcité
est ce qu'on n'a pas des difficultés en
france à faire vivre ce pilier pour
pourtant indispensables à notre
démocratie
vous dites la laïcité à la française moi
je pense que le jour viendra où la
laïcité sera beaucoup plus
universellement prises en compte
parce que je pense que c'est une
proposition de vivre ensemble dont le
monde entier a besoin regarder la
situation tragique du liban on n'en
parle pas assez en france le c'est un
pays qui est en situation de deux
condamnations à mort ont parce que les
les les luttes religieuses et tribales
l'ont déchiré au point que chacun des
libanais pense que peut-être son pays
n'a plus d'avenir et de l'autre côté du
spectre ya par exemple le modèle
britannique modèle canadien qui n'a
encore rien à voir c'est une autre forme
de laïcité de coexistence d'un
communiqué de même modèle mais enfin bon
qu'est ce que dit la laïcité elle dit
quelque chose d'extrêmement simple elle
dit il y a un univers pour le religieux
et il y a un univers pour la loi civile
et la loi religieuse ne commente pas la
loi civile pour aucun d'entre nous comme
vous savez j'ai des convictions
religieuses sans que je ne dissimule pas
je suis un croyant et et même pratiquant
comme on dit pour autant je ne peux pas
accepter que ce soit des autorités
religieuses qui commande en quoi que ce
soit la décision publique
la décision des pouvoirs publics et
quand je suis en situation de pouvoir
public je vous assure que je fais
respecter sa de la manière la plus
absolue
et c'est le seul moyen pour vivre
ensemble le chacun à l'idée qu'il se
fait de la loi divine ou supérieure et
parfois pas de convictions religieuses
et même des convictions à religieuse et
c'est tout à fait la liberté de chacun
mais nous devons avoir en tête que il y
a au dessus de tout cela notre loi notre
manière de nous respecter les uns les
autres et nous devons être inflexible de
ce point de vue là si vous me permettez
juste une phrase sur l'image que vous
avez montré j'ai trouvé que c'était un
beau geste de réconciliation
j'ai trouvé que que cette jeune fille
reçu à la grande mosquée après des
affrontements et les polémiques qui
l'ont tellement explosé c'était un
c'était un beau geste français venant là
votre dernière date note en date
brandon c'est un sujet qui lui aussi
nous concerne tous dans dans notre pays
l'agriculture notre agriculture vous
avez publié une note
en tant que haut commissaire au plan
c'était vendredi avant-hier conséquente
que j'ai compulser on constate qu'en
2020 notre production agricole a diminué
moins 1,8 pour cent selon l'insee et
vous en faites vous dites il faut qu'on
réussisse dans les années à venir à ne
pas abandonner toute notion de
productivisme mais en même temps faire
une agriculture qui est favorable à
l'environnement
on a l'impression que c'est la
quadrature du cercle par quels moyens
concrets pensez vous pouvoir arriver à
cet objectif
c'est pas la quadrature du cercle c'est
une nécessité nationale le le point où
nous en sommes et celui-ci comme vous
dites la production a baissé
la france qui était le grand pays
agricoles de toute l'europe
le plus exportateur est aujourd'hui
doublé par l'allemagne et par les pays
bas si l'on considérait sur la table de
famille uniquement ce qu'il y a dans
l'assiette et parce qu'il ya dans les
verts parce qu'on est très gros
exportateurs de vins et de spiritueux
alors c'est une image et pour ce qu'est
dans l'assiette nous sommes déficitaires
et dans le même temps il ya un paradoxe
absolument incroyable c'est que dans le
monde sur la planète
la demande alimentaire devient tel que
les prix explosent il ya des pays
entiers ou d augmentation de 40 50 70%
par exemple des céréales font que les
gens n'ont plus d'argent pour se nourrir
vous dites dans votre note que le fait
qu'on soit déficitaire c'est digne d'un
pays en développement soulevez vous
l'exprimez peut-être sur un certain
nombre de pertes cherche un produit j'ai
pris l'exemple c'est anecdotique ou en
tout cas c'est sourire nous sommes les
premiers producteurs de pommes de terre
mais nous importons nous sommes
déficitaires en chips et enfle au camp
de purée est-ce que c'est raisonnable
est-ce que c'est d'un pays équilibré on
nous a appris au lycée que les économies
des pays en voie de développement
c'était je produis des matières
premières et j'importe des produits trop
bas n'ont pas respiré élaboré
transformer en agriculture on est
exactement
pour les pommes de terre dans ce genre
de déséquilibres
donc je crois que si vous mettez d'un
côté la réalité la situation de la
france grands pays agricoles la demande
de produits agricoles dans le monde
alors on se dit mais c'est pas possible
que nous ne répondions pas à cette
demande en produisant comme nous l'avons
fait beaucoup dans les décennies passées
et en même temps si j'ose dire
mais là c'est absolument justifiés il ya
une autre demande mondiale elle aussi en
tout cas des pays en développement et
elle va devenir une demande mondiale
c'est que on a besoin de production qui
respecte les équilibres écologiques et
notamment qui respecte les équilibres
climatiques
est ce que c'est possible oui c'est
possible c'est possible on adore on a
des des progrès considérables à faire en
termes de agronomie de apprendre le
respect des sols par exemple vous avez
des productions de maïs
si à l'issue des moissons vers le mois
d'octobre vous recevez des légumineuses
à la place du maïs alors vous avez un
double effet kiss cool si j'ose dire
d'une certaine manière au bout de cette
naissance vous aurez capter du co2 vous
aurez fait des pièges à co2 vous
enrichirez les sols et vous aurez des
vers de terre et des bactéries qui se
développeront des news et moi juste
françois vers en derniers mois à ce
sujet parce que j'entends ce que vous
dites moi aussi j'ai lu votre votre note
je voudrais vous précisiez ce qu'il en
est pour les agriculteurs parce que là
on a l'impression qu'on parle
publiquement pas d'humains danser faire
on a l'impression qu'il ya pas de gens
sur les tracteurs mais qui sont en train
de pêcher et qui se suicident en très
grand nombre
je sais que c'est le cas mais j'aurais
voulu préciser non
franchement le c'est un démon de que
j'aime où j'ai mes racines j'ai grandi
où je vis et c'est parce que je pense
aux agriculteurs au moins autant que les
autres que je dis ils ont été blessés
pendant des décennies les deux dernières
décennies par l'accusation implicite que
eux qui étaient les amis de la nature et
ceux qui la comprenait le mieux il était
accusé d'en être les ennemis
ça a été pour les agriculteurs quelque
chose d'extrêmement douloureux donc
comme le monde a besoin de produits
agricoles en quantité et en qualité
alors nous nous devons être
l'agriculture en europe et dans le monde
capable de produire tout en respectant
de très hauts standards d'environnement
à une condition est entre les mains des
pouvoirs publics c'est qu'on n'impose
pas aux agriculteurs français ou
européen des normes dont on accepte que
les autres les concurrents ne les
respectent pas et là on a un problème
politique majeur et je sais que le
gouvernement y travaille et que c'est ce
après sa préoccupation
si nous ne faisons pas respecté cet
équilibre et cette équité au service des
agriculteurs pour qu'ils retrouvent der
du ont des revenus ce qui est évident le
respect par tous le monde de leur
profession et le fait qu'ils se sentent
de nouveau à l'avant garde de
l'efficacité transports de l'agriculture
et de son inscription dans le respect de
la nature
ce qu'ils ont toujours fait et par
ailleurs nous allons avancer parce que
le temps file mais je précise c'est
important les notes du haut commissariat
sont disponibles sur internet tout ce
qu'ils veulent élire peuvent seront fait
plein d'autres critères et vous avez les
trouver revenant sur les régionales
david seppuku oui alors régional avec
des résultats qui n'ont pas été bons
pour le parti du président de la
république la république en marche
ma partie qui trouve pas son ancrage
gérald darmanin par exemple a déclaré
que à en marche il faudrait faire un peu
moins de visio et plus de bistrot bon
vous vous êtes le patron du modem
votre parti à vous il a de l'ancrage
même si marc fesneau n'a pas cartonné
non plus or il a fait 17 pour ce voyage
à dire le meilleur score qu'ils aient
jamais et été réalisée de la majorité
il pensait pouvoir gagner la région bon
à savoir est ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il
faut que ce parti ce serait une offre
complètement changé ses pratiques je
parle de la république en marche moi je
parle de la majorité je pense que dans
les résultats de ces de ces élections
il ya eu deux message est un message à
l'endroit de la démocratie française
peut-être des médias vous y êtes aussi
de tous ceux qui sont les acteurs de la
démocratie française et notamment les
acteurs institutionnels les pouvoirs
successifs
les gens ont dit quelque chose de simple
je crois ils disent votre truc là
régionales départementales on n'y
comprend rien et même si je faisais une
interro écrite sur ce plateau je suis
pas sûr quand j'obtiendrai en par
exemple sur les modes d'élection sur la
loi électorale devraient impliquer sur
ces sujets là vous savez qu'il y en a
deux
oui oui au risque de perdre été
spectateur mais on fera ce quiz jeux
relève le nom après l'émission mais je
veux il faut vous avez 10 les électeurs
il ya des scrutins de liste on connaît
personne de l'autre parent ya des
tickets mixtes avec quatre personnes sur
le ticket et c'est pas la même loi
électorale et on sait pas ce que ça leur
appartient pas quelle est la différence
entre les départements et les régions
ça c'est le premier message on n'y
comprend rien si vous simplifiez pas ça
nous on décroche ce que je ne crois pas
que ce vote soit un vote de désintérêt
aux sept abstentions je pense que c'est
une abstention de sécession c'est on
veut plus que vous ne preniez comme
otages élections auxquelles on ne
comprend rien et qui ne change pas le
monde
ça c'est le premier message deuxième
message il ya un message à l'endroit des
forces de la majorité
un faux pas faire semblant de se cacher
derrière son petit doigt
il ya un message de 2 s'est pas
identifié pour les électeurs il ya même
pas d'étiquette commune sur les
bulletins y avait pas une étiquette qui
permet de reconnaître les moutons dans
sa bergerie
on sait pas qui est qui on évitait dans
la plupart soigneusement de dire qu'elle
était l'orientation de ces listes
je pense que c'est une erreur je pense
qu'il faut reconstruire une identité
fonds européens et je pense que cette
identité doit être fondée sur en effet
un rassemblement des rassemblements une
manière de vivre ensemble plus large ça
fait d'aimer jésuites dont on entend
parler françois bayrou quand est ce que
vous allez le faire c'est dire ça fait
des mois qu'on entend parler de ça c'est
là la maison commune vous aurez observer
que si j'étais facile probablement
serait et effet plus plus vite mais là
il me semble que il ya besoin
et pourquoi pas de se tenir en
respectant ce que chacun ait et en
respectant ce que chacun a le verbe être
et le verbe avoir
et je pense que si ces deux précautions
sont remplies adorons peu avancé et
qu'il faudra le spare à la rente
bonsoir à tous cette partie jeu
après mais cent des parts d'un parti et
très accessoirement le conseil vous
donneriez à xavier bertrand mais d'abord
sur la primaire est ce que c'est le
meilleur
est ce que c'est le moyen le plus
efficace c'est le pire est ailleurs
c'est alors je sais pas que je sois du
côté des hommes du côté des autres c'est
le pire parfois il est inévitable et
l'ice qu on sait revient un pouf lyon 2
shoots pas d'être membre des républiques
cheveux de mpa mais on pouvait avoir un
avis tout mais toute ma vie politique a
été construite autour d'un pilier c'est
que la vie politique c'est un pluralisme
il ya une gauche et même sans doute
plusieurs gauches il ya des écologistes
il ya une droite extrême droite il ya un
centre et toute ma vie politique j'ai
refusé la confusion entre centre et
droite
quand on vous dit candidat de la droite
et du centre avec des traits d'union
entre les deux c'est une escroquerie
parce que si vous êtes dans le côté
alors vous n'êtes pas centre ça veut
dire mais surtout pour nos mii du centre
adam en démocrates et républicains si
vous considérez qu'on ne peut pas être
du centre et de la droite emmanuel
macron est à droite du but 90e emmanuel
macron et le la figure de proue de ce
grand courant en europe pas seulement en
france et le parti démocrate est au
pouvoir aux états unis et quand vous
regardez baden baden les propos qu'il
tient et les décisions qu'il prend sont
exactement à l' équilibre de ce courant
central dont un qui mérite d'être
identifié et est enraciné et j'ai
toujours plaidé ça vous souvenez que
j'allais à toulouse un jour il ya
longtemps pour dire vous dites qu'on
pense tous la même chose si on pense
tout de même chose c'est qu'on ne pense
plus rien et donc je je je
croix à l'identité et à l'autonomie du
grand art pour en centrale et en effet
je dis depuis le début que les primaires
ça mais ça ne paraissait pas la
meilleure solution
parfois il y en a pas d'autre françois
bayrou je vais vous obliger à vous
remémorer un souvenir désagréable en
vous êtes garde des sceaux et vous
prenez la décision de démissionner non
et vous si de quitter le gouvernement de
quitter gouvernement parce que vous
dites fin de cette conférence de presse
où dit il il ya des soupçons qui pèsent
c'est le sujet des attachés
parlementaires parlement européen du
modem il ya des soupçons qui pèsent et
qui vont gêner l'action du gouvernement
il ya une loi très importante
moralisation de la vie publique et vous
dites
dans ces conditions il faut quitter ce
gouvernement je ne comprends pas bien et
peut-être pourriez-vous m'expliquer quel
est la différence avec la situation qui
est celle de monsieur eric
dupond-moretti aujourd'hui qui est le
qui fait l'objet d'une enquête de la
cour de justice de la république qui est
convoquée vendredi prochain 16 juillet
dans la en vue d'une mise en examen et
dont on nous explique que quoi qu'il
arrive il ne démissionnera pas
quelle est la différence françois bayrou
la différence c'est l'idée que chacun se
fait de son engagement alors je précise
nous n'avons pas démissionné simplement
nous avons dit au président de la
république j'ai dit marielle de sarnez
y'avait madame goulard nous avons dit au
président de la république que nous ne
participerons pas au gouvernement qu'il
allait former oui oui oui
enfin oui vous avez quoi les miens
vernement vous avez un tel gouvernement
j'ai quitté en effet ses fonctions qui
étaient passionnantes pour lesquels
j'avais des idées pour une raison simple
j'ai pensé moi je dis pas que les autres
pensaient la même chose j'ai pensé moi
je ne pourrais pas exercer sereinement
les fonctions avec cette pression cette
perpétuelle ce perpétuel soupçons
avec la sortie d'information en presse
de dire que dans notre cas et je le
maintiens aujourd'hui devant vous toutes
ces accusations sont fausses et que nous
aurons l'occasion
j'espère un jour de le prouver
l'instruction est toujours en cours
oui et on n'en est pas de nouvelles
depuis 18 mois et donc
et pourquoi est ce que monsieur
duchesneau rainsy pourrait exercer
serait bien le poste de mise c'est ça
alors il est lui aussi sous le coup
d'une encaisse c'était lui des
accusations assez lourde est à lui au
président de la république qu'il
convient d'en décider
moi je j'ai décidé pour moi même pour
mon propre cas j'ai décidé avec
détermination
je les dis au président de la république
dès que l' enquête a commencé à sortir
mais le président de la république et le
garde des sceaux peuvent avoir un autre
jugement
je comprends très bien ce qui ce qu'ils
ont en paix tu sais on ne peut pas
laisser des juges décider de la
formation d'un gouvernement parce que
c'est d'une certaine manière trop facile
vous lancer des accusations des enquêtes
des mises en examen et faisant fi de la
présomption d'innocence
eh bien vous vous trouvez obligé de
quitter le gouvernement dans les dents
soit là riom par exemple a eu raison de
se maintenir candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2017
quand il a été mis en examen le la
situation de françois fillon est
aujourd'hui éclairé par des par la suite
il a été condamné mais pendant la
campagne présidentielle on est sur une
mise en examen il est présumé innocent
mais il n'était pas membre de l'exécutif
mais il s'est maintenu candidats bon
chacun juge pour lui même d'accord
est-ce qu'on vous étiez mis en examen
vendredi et basse il jouera selon vous
restez et ce qu'ils induisent julien
tient à l'avocat pour penser redon est
ce que vous pensez qu'à une revanche des
juges notamment
je crois qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
déclarations hostiles camp
monsieur dupont moretti a été nommé et
ça éclaire d'une certaine manière
l'ambiance mais c'est à lui de décider
c'est au président de la république
cela nous ramène également françois
bayroux si vous le permettez
potentiellement à au désintérêt des
français pour une partie de la chose
politique
avec au delà du fond que vous venez
d'évoquer avec justesse mais il ya des
déclarations qui sont faites par les
gens qui arrivent au pouvoir qui réclame
d'être des modèles qui réclament
d'autres modèles de société ce qui était
le cas des matches et vont à leur tour
une mauvaise organisation de la vie
publique
est ce que les français je les six
filles intrigue lorsqu'il assiste
ensuite à cela ça crée forcément un
minimum défiance à minima c'est une
défiance
alors vous avez raison mais il faut
aller plus loin car la défiance
aujourd'hui elle porte au moins autant
sur la justice sur l'attitude de ces
justiciables particuliers que sont les
membres du gouvernement moi je pense que
il ya une ambiguïté que la justice ou
certains de ceux qui la commentent la
vive ou la souhaite comme un
contre-pouvoir est pour moi la justice
ait pas un contre pouvoir
la justice c'est une autorité impartiale
elle n'est pas là pour dézinguer des
pouvoirs pour les fragiliser pour
montrer que ce sont des colosses aux
pieds d'argile ils le sont l'univers
médiatique aux réseaux sociaux
sortie de documents déformés c'est un
piège perpétuelle ils sont en effet
fragile mais la justice elle devrait
être là pour assurer l'impartialité et
notamment pour différencier ce qui est
grave de ce qui ne l'est pas un dernier
mot un dernier mot peut-être sur la date
de l'élection présidentielle on en a
beaucoup parlé est ce que vous pensez
que c'est a priori sur la table mais on
cei selon d'excellentes informations de
notre confrère david dos quand ça se
répète pas forcément les 10 et le 24
avril dans tous les cas c'est ce qu'on a
entendu
est-ce que
cette date vous paraît en fonction des
ponts du 1er mai des vacances etc
excusez nous paraît la meilleure des
dates où la pire des dates pour
reprendre votre expression
alors on a le choix entre 10 et 24 avril
et 17 est tout à fait voulez savoir le
fond de ce que je pense mais je m'en
fiche mais même à ce que ça n'empechera
pas l'immense pièce dramatique le battre
la construction dramatique qu est
toujours une élection présidentielle
quelle que soit la date et on a toujours
les mêmes coups de théâtre les mêmes
bouleversements pour une fonction qui en
effet mérite que l'attention du pays ce
poste merci
alors je reconnais que le premier mais
les gens sont l'habitude de partir ça
fait deux très longs week-ends jeu mais
sur le fond ça ne changera merci
beaucoup françois bayrou d'avoir été
notre invité pour cette dernière de la
saison de bfm politique merci beaucoup à
des visages merci david c'est un plaisir
de partager cette saison avec vous
partager dans un instant vous allez
retrouver philippe bauden dominique
rizet d'affaires suivante et je vous
donne rendez-vous pour dernier numéro
des fm tv sd de la saison année
m